what we've seen in direct to consumer is
that if the product
is really transcendent and the marketing
is really
um clever then there's a really good
chance for a great outcome in terms of
connecting with customers and
as a business is that your experience as
well that in order to win at d2c
the product has to be differentiated and
you have to have some sort of
marketing approach a go-to market
approach that is either unique or
world-class totally i mean once upon a
time
you know you could definitely go to
alibaba find some products repackage it
build a really shiny website turn on
your facebook you know faucet
and there you go you can build it
probably a couple million dollars
uh you know business that way but as
custom acquisition costs go up on
facebook google all of these channels
there isn't really that arbitrage on you
know marketing anymore so
i do think fundamentally it is about
business fundamentals right customers
only care about
differentiated products that are better
than incumbents not just with a shiny
coat and so we take us for example you
know we
we spent i think 14 months on
just the fabrics of our sofa we
basically said that there's no fabrics
out there in the market everybody knows
umbrella everybody knows some of these
other performance
outdoor fabrics but they don't meet our
uh
requirements when it comes to comfort
durability and eco-friendliness
especially the the third
eco-friendliness component and so
we decided to set out to kind of find
our own yarn suppliers
really to understand how fabrics are
woven and made and
it iterated on a lot and and that turned
out to be a very differentiated offering
and so it's wine proof you can pour
coffee on it we have a video on youtube
of
us pouring black coffee on this white uh
you know fabrics and just wipes right
off with water and so
um i do think it's detailed product uh
decisions like that that can really
build a brand uh in
2021 and that's requires understanding
the product in market over time and
constantly iterating correct like you
have to understand where this product
lives
outdoors in the rain in the sun and that
is
you know when anybody who's bought
outdoor furniture before knows this
pattern of like
you buy outdoor furniture it gets
stained you buy expensive covers they
get stains you cover them
and then you stop using your furniture
because it's covered and the it's
arduous to take all the covers off put
all the covers back on it's just it
becomes like um
an annoyance right uh and then you wind
up buying stuff that doesn't have sofas
because you want just benches and then
those are uncomfortable you don't use
them
i've been through this like being a you
know california boy for the last
decade or so more now yeah getting close
to two decades
it's just a lot of work outdoor
furniture correct
that's right i mean i grew up in alabama
uh and you know
outdoor living is a thing you know
tailgating uh everyone has a yard
um and obviously having moved to la for
almost a decade you know outdoor living
is definitely like a lifestyle over here
it's just so nice today it's actually
like balmy today it's like has been
really cold but
yeah i mean totally it's all of these uh
kind of
it's like waking up in the morning you
have a coffee in hand you want to go
outside just sit down at your couch
right and
you have to now put your coffee down
remove this huge rain tarp that's
probably covered
in dust and bird poop and you don't want
to touch it and then
and then and then you know and then
after you do it the cushion's still damp
you know from the dew and you sit on it
without knowing that and you
your butt is wet call it now you gotta
change your underwear
change your pants it's a disaster it's a
disaster yeah and the cover that you
guys came up with is so clever because
it was designed to be easy to use right
you just flip it right over boom you're
done
just like a laptop lid one hand so
coffee in hand or phone on the other
hand you can just use one hand and
open it up it even after it closes like
in
in the clamshell format it has a little
handle because if there's a torrential
rain that's come rainstorm that's coming
you can just
pick up all the cushions in one go
instead of stacking up stacking them up
like pizza boxes and
you know so it's uh that
is definitely the number one we have
like a looping animation of outer shell
in action
it's like a five second animation it
went viral on instagram
uh and i think everybody relates to that
pain point
it does there is something about
marketing on social media where if you
make a nice gif or you make a nice
looped video
it can really pull people in and and
this is i love this escalation of
excellence that's occurred everybody is
looking whether it's you
with outdoor furniture or ate sleep one
of our investments that is working on
beds you know they just sit there all
day long and they go how can
we make sleeping you know how can we get
people better sleep through this product
i mean they're literally doing that with
software and you know hardware and
just the design of the app and
everything
listen 2020 was a crazy hectic insane
year my god it was like a decade in a
year
and there was a lot of uncertainty let's
face it but we're going to minimize our
uncertainty in 2021 and we are going to
start the roaring 20 so let's switch
to a smooth and painless payroll and hr
system gusto is
that system and it wasn't just built for
small businesses it was built for the
people behind them that's you
and me their online payroll is so easy
to use gusto can
automatically calculate paychecks and
file all your payroll taxes easy peasy
three out of four customers say they run
their payroll
in 10 minutes or less which means you
can get back
to your business heidi who manages
operations here at launch
she says gusto frees her up to do more
business critical tasks like running our
syndicate
they offer unlimited payrolls for one
monthly price there are no hidden fees
and
they help with time tracking a lot of
people need to do that health insurance
critically important 401ks
be generous with your employees
onboarding commuter benefits offer
letters
access to hr experts and more and if
you're moving from another provider
gusto is going to transfer all your data
for you
no surprise 94 customers are likely to
recommend gusto to
a friend of course they are because it's
so easy here's the best part because
you're a twist listener you're gonna get
three months totally free
all you have to do is go to gusto.com
twist that's gusto.com
twist